now you have you know uh members of the
security state or former members like
Petraeus like Panetta like kinzinger
saying that if there is a nuclear use by
Russia in Ukraine that we must get
directly involved in this war we must
now bomb every Russian military asset in
Ukraine sink every ship that Russia has
in the Black Sea this is what you know
very respected people in the Beltway are
calling for so we could this could tip
over into a hot war in which we are a
full belligerent at any minute
foreign
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the founder of craft Ventures and one of
the co-hosts of the all in podcast David
sacks welcome back to the Reuben report
great to be with you Dave good to see
you David uh when I contacted you a
couple weeks ago to come back on it was
because you were getting all sorts of
people very angry at you over this
ukraine-russia thing and it's bizarre at
least from where I sit because to me
you've been one of kind of the like most
sober hey let's not rush into war what
are we doing here is this costing us
money and all sorts of stuff that's the
voice that you have been but I didn't
even know you really cared about uh
international relations to this extent
before that so uh maybe for people that
don't know you or or why we're even
having this conversation maybe we should
start there why did you get involved in
this whole conversation
well I can't imagine an issue that is
more important to all of us and whether
we get in World War III and it was Biden
himself it was Biden himself who said
just the other day that the United
States was at the risk of getting into
what he called Armageddon uh he said
that we Face the most serious risk of
getting into a nuclear war since the
Cuban Missile Crisis and the one time
you can really believe Biden is when
he's off prompter right he's saying
things spontaneously off the cuff so I
actually believe that this is what he
thinks and these are the conversations
that are happening inside the White
House and so I think we all should be
very concerned about where this war is
leading Us in terms of my interest I
mean foreign policy has been an interest
of mine for a while but when I saw what
was happening on this issue and where it
was leading and specifically we're in an
escalatory spiral with Russia which is
you know another nuclear power it's the
country in the world that has the most
nuclear weapons it's really the only
country in the world that can and truly
threaten our own security because of the
sheer number of icbms that they have
this is the only Achilles heel that we
really have our military is so vastly
more powerful than anybody else no one
can really touch us except for this one
issue of ICBM so they do pose a real
threat to us so we need to be very
concerned about where where this
escalatory spiral is headed and look my
interest is really just coming at it
from the point of view of being a
concerned American and I do this podcast
called the all in pod every week where
we talk about this issue
and for expressing any concerns about
where this war is headed you're
instantly denounced as some sort of
Putin apologist or agent of the Kremlin
or something like that and just to be
completely clear I have no Financial
dealings with Russia or anyone from
Russia I invest in American startups uh
so you know I have no interest in this
other than coming out from the point of
view of a concerned American
and for complete transparency sake you
also were an investor in locals and
obviously then we merged with Rumble and
and all good so we've been a very worthy
startup but yes these are the types of
this is what I do is I invest in
startups in American companies and David
I can give you my word I'm not a Russian
operative so you're you're clear on my
end okay so so look I actually have not
covered Russia Ukraine a ton on the show
because I I my general feeling is
there's so much going on in the United
States right now domestically that is
wrong I I've been just kind of keeping
my eye on that a little bit more but my
general thoughts have been you've got
two Sovereign countries here you can't
invade a sovereign country but at the
same time once he does it and the guy
with the big guns with the nukes if you
don't give him an off ramp we could
really be in a lot of trouble and I
think that's sort of where you've been
going with all of this
um are you shocked the way people have
pushed back on hey let's not go to World
War III in your Newsweek piece you
talked about this sort of Confluence of
now the walksters and the neocons who
you think have nothing in common how
they're really the driving force of this
whole thing now
right well just let's take an example so
Elon Musk proposed on Twitter a simple
straw man for a peace deal it was a very
um I think pretty reasonable framework
it basically said that listen we will do
elections in these disputed territories
in eastern Ukraine not sham elections
but elections under the supervision of
say the United Nations peacekeepers and
election monitors we recognize that
Crimea is a fat accompli Russia annexed
in 2014 that ship has sailed
um and you know we we recognize that uh
that Ukraine will not become part of
NATO which Russia feels is very
threatening to their own security but we
can give them we can sell them weapons
and give them security guarantees that
was roughly the proposal by the way that
those rough Contours of a peace deal
have been suggested by many experts for
over a year to resolve this crisis but
in any event my point is this that he
was denounced by no less than zelinski
himself yeah who took to Twitter to
basically say that the mere suggestion
of a peace deal was acting in
pro-russian interests so this is the
point in the debate that we've reached
is that if you raise even the idea of
trying to find a diplomatic solution to
this war or if you bring up any of the
pre-history to what happened before
February 24th if you point out that the
West desire for NATO expansion right up
to NATO's right up to Russia's front
front porch might have played a role in
creating this conflict if you you know
bring up any idea that that's sort of
not on board with I would say maximalist
Ukrainian demands to take back every
square inch of territory that they
consider theirs then you are now
pro-russian in a Kremlin agent where do
you think or or what do you think that
that says about zelenski that he
obviously is outgunned here he's getting
out you know a crazy amount of money and
all sorts of weapons and technology and
everything else from all over the world
but as you say he's maximalist on get
the hell out of here guy with nukes and
that doesn't seem normally how the the
symmetry of something like this would
play out as Kamala Harris said Russia
big Ukraine small
well so I think you know you at the
beginning of the war zielinski himself
was floating peace deals that were not
dissimilar from what Elon suggested he
said that he was open to uh taking the
issue of NATO expansion off the table
and then unfortunately Boris Johnson
went to Ukraine in April and killed that
peace deal and now since then there have
been so many losses on both sides but
especially the ukrainians have suffered
so much that there's no longer any
appetite for a peace deal uh I I
understand that this is what happens in
war is that people experience so much
loss so much Devastation that they get
more dug in on their position and
zielinski is following a position of
Ukrainian nationalism that is what his
country supports now I think the mistake
would be for us even though I think we
sympathize with their Ukrainian
nationalism their desire for sovereignty
I think that we have to consider what's
in America's own interest Solinski is
representing what's in his own own
country it's interest what's in UK group
cranes interest but we need to think
about what's in the United States's
interest and the fact of the matter is
we are getting increasingly drawn in to
this conflict in a deeper and deeper way
to the point where now we actually might
face the risk of a nuclear war and I
think it's about time that somebody on
the American side started saying listen
we understand the Ukrainian position on
this we sympathize with you we're
willing to give you aid but what are our
limits what is in the American interest
and those are the questions we'd be
asking right now do you think this
Administration has the American interest
at heart
well at the beginning of the war Biden
said some sensible things so for example
what he said is that the U.S would not
get directly involved in a shooting war
with Russia he understood and said that
could cause World War III we're not
messing around with that and so for
example he vetoed the idea of a no-fly
zone which hardliners you know the
Twitter mob wanted and you know various
uh Congressional Elites Lindsey Graham
and so forth wanted yeah that was a
smart decision also when Lester Holt
asked him in a press interview at the
very beginning of the war he said Mr
President what if there's Americans
trapped Behind Enemy Lines would you
send in our troops to go get them and
Biden said no you know even in that case
we will not get directly involved in
this war he didn't let the Press goad
him into a direct American involvement
but the problem is that since then we've
been on a slippery slope and we've
begotten more and more involved so for
example you've now had Administration
officials brag to Publications like the
the New York Times And The Washington
Post about killing Russian generals
providing the intelligence that paints
the Target on their back about providing
the intelligence the artillery
responding to sink the most which is the
Russian Flagship you've had
Administration officials bragging about
the role they played in this recent
Ukrainian counteroffensive basically the
ukrainians presented plans to the
American generals the Americans said
these plans are good enough they hand
corrected them sent them back to Ukraine
and they're bragging about this in the
New York Times we also keep
appropriating them more and more money
more and more weapons and more and more
advanced weapons and so we are getting
more and more involved there's also was
a New York Times report about how
American America now has Commandos we
have boots on the ground in Ukraine
maybe not pulling the triggers or
pushing the buttons on the high Mars and
so forth but they're on the ground
directing the flow of weaponry and Aid
and so they are In Harm's Way and they
could get killed thereby drawing us and
even further so we are very involved in
this war Dave and we're getting more
involved by the day it's interesting
because we call it this war we don't
really say our war but do you think
we're in in essence do you think I know
we haven't declared war and this hasn't
gone to Congress and any of that kind of
stuff but do you feel like we actually
are at War right now like what do you
think the average American should feel
like I mean we're funding it seemingly
endlessly as you said weapons and
training and a whole bunch more I mean
do you think in essence we are at War
whether it's declared or not
we we are basically at the point now
where we are effectively a cop
belligerent in this war in the sense
that like you said we're providing the
weapons we're training the ukrainians on
how to use those weapons including on
American soil we are providing the
intelligence for providing the battle
plans
um we are doing everything except for
pulling the triggers and taking the
bullets which and I don't want to
minimize that because the ukrainians are
suffering a lot of losses but we are
this close to basically being directly
involved and now you have you know uh
members of the security state or former
members like Petraeus like Panetta like
kinzinger saying that if there is a
nuclear use by Russia in Ukraine that we
must get directly involved in this war
we must now bomb every Russian military
asset in Ukraine sync every ship that
Russia has in the Black Sea this is what
you know very respected people in the
Beltway are calling for so we could this
could tip over into a hot war in which
we are are a full belligerent at any
minute and you know I think that we need
to be thinking about why would we do
that the fact the matter is that prior
to this year no American president in
the history of the United States ever
declared Ukraine or any part of Ukraine
to be a vital interest the United States
we do not have a vital National interest
in who rules the donbass or Crimea we
simply don't that by the way is and
Biden realized that's the beginning of
the war this is why he said we will not
get directly involved is because he
realized that America did not have a
vital National interest but we through
the slippery slope are getting closer
and closer to getting into a war with
Russia which could be a nuclear war even
though we have no vital interests at
stake so if we don't have a vital
interest there putting aside okay a
certain amount of people just like war
or the idea of war or the profiteering
off War you know a lot of people are
saying this is just basically the
biggest money laundering scheme in
history that's sort of Afghanistan
wrapped up and that's somehow how a ton
of money laundering happened and now
it's just been shifted to Ukraine do you
think think there is validity to that
yeah I mean the argument was this was uh
I think put uh in in a clever way that
you know the idea was that you had
Afghanistan on one end and on the other
hand was the American well sorry you had
the American taxpayer on one end on the
other end was basically the military
industrial complex and in between was
this laundry machine that washed all the
money and kept it going we had that for
20 years in Afghanistan it was uh an
operation that cost us literally
trillions of dollars
um you know the total bill for all of
our Miss begotten adventures in the
Middle East these forever Wars is
roughly eight trillion dollars and it
was only six months after the Afghan war
finally was ended after 20 years of us
not even knowing what we're doing there
anymore I guess we're on some crazy
nation building project but after 20
years of that we only went six months
without there being a new war basically
declared that is a Full Employment
Program for the military industrial
complex now look I think the motivations
for this are more complicated than just
that I think there's a strong
ideological component but there's no
question that if you peel back the
layers of who funds these think tanks
that are always clamoring for war that
are funding all these you know blue
checks on Twitter who basically are
clamoring for more and more involvement
it is there's a lot of Defense
contractors who basically are footing
the bills for these think tanks and it's
high time in my opinion that these think
tanks and so forth and these columnists
who we're always bringing for war
disclose who their donors are I mean
they're constantly accusing people on
the side who want a diplomatic solution
of somehow being
pro-russian sympathizers I've already
declared I have no Russian investors I
have no Russian interest can they
declare the same thing about Ukrainian
oligarchs and by the way we know what
was Hunter Biden doing receiving
millions of dollars from Ukrainian
oligarchs just shortly before this war
started so there are connections here
that I think deserve to be explored
right and then just watching the
reaction to your Newsweek piece which I
thought was excellent I'm going to quote
a couple lines of it in a moment and
then watching when Elon put the Twitter
poll up which we did Cover and all of
these people who you'd think would have
respect for Elon Musk at least maybe
they don't care about his politics but
like all right he's an interesting guy
maybe he'd we need to like mix this
thing up a little bit just watching
people go after him
now right now they're saying uh who was
it that was it Lindsey Graham that said
maybe we should look into some of his
government contracts or something after
that right yeah exactly and David Frum
said that we should nationalize starlink
so so but yeah both of them said that so
so but here's the amazing thing is Elon
Musk is the reason why a big part of the
reason why Ukraine is still in this war
without starlink which is Elon satellite
communication system which allows
ukrainians to get internet access in the
field in the most remote parts of
Ukraine the Ukrainian military effort
would not have communications and this
is is what is basically powering their
tablets and their targeting systems and
their drones is that they have internet
access through starlink Elon said that
that that's spacex's company has borne
this they donated starlink to the
Ukrainian cause at a out-of-pocket costs
them of 80 million dollars it's about 20
million dollars a month and when Elon
finally said listen we're not seeking
payment for the donation we made in the
past but moving forward we can't afford
as an unprofitable company to keep
funding this you know we'd like to get
paid like maybe uh Lockheed or uh you
know Lockheed Martin or Raytheon these
defense contractors are making massive
amounts of money selling javelins or
high Mars maybe we'd like to get paid
like that there was this hysterical
reaction by people like Lindsey Graham
buy people like David from who somehow
feel entitled to conscript a private
American company into funding this war
forever and by the way it's worth noting
that David Frum was George W Bush's
speech right who wrote the axis of Evil
speech that got us into the Iraq War
you'd think that these people would have
a little bit of shame or a little bit of
humility but they just keep coming back
I guess that's what your point is that
there's this yeah this they recycle
these same people basically who get
everything wrong yeah I think it's a
really important point that the exact
same people who are supporting greater
and greater involvement in the uh in
this war by America who say that any
diplomatic solution would be appeasement
and would be pro-putin they are the
exact same people who lied us into Iraq
who lied us into literally with uh the
false claims of wmd programs and the
false claims that Saddam Hussein was
somehow Linked UP And In Cahoots with Al
Qaeda so they made that up they also
made up this the the that somehow we
needed to be in Afghanistan for 20 years
they light us into Syria they light us
into Libya their foreign policy has been
a disaster for the last 20 years these
are not people who should be trusted as
experts and yet they claim I'm in a
Twitter spot right now with a guy named
Tom Nichols who literally they're all
writers at the Atlantic by the way yeah
the Atlantic is like the most pro-war
magazine and yet you'll get Lincoln
project next it starts
yeah Stuart Stevens is hitting me too by
the way Stuart Stevens this guy is a
political Hitman for a hire who has
literally worked for foreign autocrats
okay so and and members of the Lincoln
project have actually taken Russian
money in the past to Lobby on behalf of
Russia and these political Hitmen are
coming after me on Twitter for
advocating peace any event none of these
people should be trusted they are not
experts they are I guess you call them
failed experts and they claim that they
are in possession of special knowledge
special abilities they have special
credentials that should make all of us
defer to them well look in my business
which is investing what do you look at
you look at a track record these people
have a track record of being nothing but
wrong for 20 years and we need to stop
listening to them and taking everything
they say at face value also have any of
them you know I've seen some of the
Twitter spats that you've got into and
most usually they're honestly just
insulting you they're not really coming
back with the ideas which surprise
surprise that's sort of what Twitter is
at this point but has anyone come back
to you and said well actually this is
what the win looks like like actually if
we just keep funding him and we just
keep giving him weapons and just enough
money that actually Russia will fold I
mean a few weeks ago they remember there
were like two or three days where people
were like Russia is losing and I was
like well again he still has the nukes
and but now nobody's saying Russia is
losing anymore
right so so you're right in terms of
like the the responses that I get on
Twitter is precious few arguments it's
really just one ad hominem attack after
another we've seen this before in
domestic politics right it's woke
cancellation tactics that they don't
respond to you by citing rational
arguments and logic they try to accuse
you of something they're not trying to
participate in the debate they're trying
to shut down the debate and so we see on
this Ukraine war is a marriage of this
sort of woke mob with these neocons
these sort of hawkish neocons who've
been wrong about everything in foreign
policy for the last 20 years and this
marriage has come together and the
reason why it's so dangerous is because
it's shaping our discourse in a way to
basically preclude and exclude any
discussion of a diplomatic settlement
and if you basically delegitimize
anybody who is basically speaking up for
peace as somehow being pro-russian you
take those options off the table so what
is left all that's left is greater
escalation more dangerous escalation
with a logical result that we could
eventually find ourselves in a war with
Russia I'm going to either do you a
major favor right now or you're going to
be pissed at me but if I can get
kinzinger or from or one of these guys
to debate you I mean my my feelings on
this are clear so I'm guessing that they
won't do it but if I can get him to do
it would you be down to do it just to be
clear yeah sure I mean yes I mean I'm
already debating him on Twitter they
don't really have an answer I mean you
know anyway yeah I mean if you read look
I read all their tweets so I understand
where they're coming from basically it's
just one a straw man in accusation after
another they they really are not
interested in finding a diplomatic
solution here and here's why this is so
dangerous is that
if you listen to what they're saying
they believe that the only accessible
outcome to this war is total Ukrainian
Victory which they are letting Ukrainian
nationalists determine what that means
and what the ukrainians say is that they
want back every square inch of Ukraine
going back to 2014. so that includes
Crimea Crimea is where the rubber meets
the road on this because I think that
most
I'd say or many foreign policy experts
who've really looked at this understand
that Putin and Russia will never let
Crimea go back they will be willing to
use Battlefield nukes to prevent the
total loss their total defeat in this
war and to prevent Crimea from being
overrun and retaken by Ukraine why is
that because Russia has a giant Naval
Base at sevastopol in Crimea which is
home to the Black Sea Fleet if they lose
Crimea they presumably lose sevastopol
they lose the Black Sea Fleet that is a
vital interest to them this would be
like if the United States were to lose
Hawaii and Pearl Harbor Putin will never
give that up he will be willing to use
Battlefield nukes to prevent that now by
the way that doesn't mean he won't be
willing to use them prior to that but I
think at the at the very latest I think
that he would be willing to use them or
so I believe in so many people believe
so this idea that we can just support
Ukrainian maximalist demands until they
overrun Crimea or this turns into a
nuclear war at some point we're going
gonna have to set the ukrainians down
zielinski down and say sorry we've
supported you to this point whatever
this is but you cannot have Korea back
we are not willing to let this conflict
go nuclear did you happen to catch any
of Rand Paul when he was asking the
Congress or he was asking the Senate
basically the house you know hey guys
we're giving them all this money can we
just get some receipts on this stuff and
basically everyone just made fun of him
I mean all the guy was saying was hey if
we're going to give them 20 billion a
pop could we just a couple receipts
would that be okay and we just simply
don't do it do we
what Rand Paul asked for was an
accountant literally an accountant it's
called it's called a special Inspector
General yeah but that's it's a fancy
name for an accountant okay you said
listen we're appropriating over 40
billion dollars in this bill by the way
the tab now is up to something like 80.
okay we need to know where this money
goes because by the way okay in
Afghanistan we didn't know how much
money was wasted until they appointed a
special Inspector General named John F
sapko and he has written report after
report of the malfeasance and what went
wrong in Ukraine and how this money was
sponsored by the way that guy deserves a
medal of honor from the next president
because what he's turned up is shocking
and to now go into a new war
appropriating tens of billions of
dollars more than we appropriate for our
own border security and not have so much
of an accountant keeping track of where
the money is going and by the way
Ukraine is one of the most corrupt
countries in the world okay Russian
Ukraine are basically like one space
apart art in the listings of national
corruption and by the way I mean listen
I know zelinski is a hero to a lot of
people but the Panama papers revealed
that he had hundreds of millions of
dollars squirreled away offshore with um
with Ukrainian oligarchs who have been
involved in various corruption scandals
so listen I mean the corruption in that
country is massive for us to be
appropriating billions of dollars
without an accountant is shocking and I
just don't understand how Congress can
do that what do you make of the sort of
swarm effect like right when this thing
happened remember those three days where
immediately okay everybody has to put
the Ukraine flag on there Twitter and
Facebook avatar and then you know EA
Sports takes the Russian national team
off PlayStation hockey literally and
we're moving vodka out of stores and all
of this Insanity what do you make of
that just sort of that Collective sort
of brain dump that everyone does when
these things happen and they turn out to
actually do nothing or if anything
you're harming Russian you know you're
harming some guy who lives in Brooklyn
who's a vodka importer you're not
harming Vladimir Putin listen I think it
was an emotional knee-jerk reaction to
the invasion I mean look the fact of the
matter is the media has not been
covering what's been going on in Ukraine
prior to February 24th so the American
people tuned in for the first time when
the invasion happened and naturally they
had a reaction of outrage and revulsion
to what the Russians were doing however
did that knee-jerk reaction results in
anything good one of the things you saw
is that American companies all left
Russia and they left literally billions
and billions of dollars of assets on the
table with the result now who paid the
price for that American Pension funds
who own the stocks of these companies
who've lost all of this money billions
and billions were lost by the way if
Putin had simply nationalized those
assets and taken them away from American
companies we would have been screaming
about theft because it would have been
theft right so I think some of the
actions we've taken in response to the
outrage and I understand the outrage and
and I understand that people can be
genuinely outraged but this is a time
for cooler heads prevail and now we're
at the point where the outrage may take
us all the way into nuclear war if we're
not careful so it is high time to move
past the outrage and to start having
some cooler heads prevail here is there
anyone politically in America that you
know that that's in politics a senator
or I guess it's not the president that's
making some sense to you on all of this
because it's funny I mean I'm looking at
my list of people that are making sense
on this and it's a lot of tech guys and
it's you know people that are that are
cultural commentators and YouTubers but
it's not really the political people
again I would exclude Rand Paul he's
making some sense there's probably a
couple others but by and large that's
true so you know the people who I listen
to so again you know I look at track
record you know I always try to ask well
who predicted this situation who who
understood that we were about to get
into this who recommended pass for
avoiding this conflict and if you go
back and look there were many people
just not the ones that Washington pays
attention to back in the 1990s you had
George Kennan who was the architect of
our Cold War containment policy warned
that if we brought NATO expansion all
the way up to Russia's border it would
result in a tragic mistake you had
basically back in in 2014 after the
um after you had this sort of Crimea
crisis you had the international
relations scholar John meersheimer
explained that we were on a course that
was headed for War I really urge
everybody to watch his lecture from 2014
on YouTube it's gone viral it has 28
million views yeah
to get to it to get a deeper
understanding any of this conflict
listen to people like Jeffrey Sachs
who's the International Development
Economist very liberal guy I mean this
is somebody who I think had a lot of
relationships in the Obama White House
who basically will affirm that this
conflict began before February 24th it
really began years ago with America
trying to bring NATO right up to
Russia's front porch remember in the
Cuban Missile Crisis what provoked that
why was America willing to use nuclear
weapons because Russia had entered into
an alliance a military alliance with
Cuba and was trying to move missiles
right onto our border we reacted
strongly to that we were willing to get
into a nuclear war over that because we
realized the military threat but we
refused to recognize that the Russians
could basically perceive American
missiles and bases directly on the most
vulnerable border which is Ukraine as a
similar kind of threat and it's been our
unwillingness to take the NATO expansion
issue off the table which we could have
done earlier this year we could have
done it in December we could have done
it in January the administration refused
to do it if we had done that I do not
believe there'd be a war today
do you think the March for the NATO
expansion or for Ukraine to get a NATO
is going to continue
yes I mean so so here's the tell on this
is that the very same people who say
this war has nothing to do with NATO
expansion people like McFall and and you
know various others in the next breath
they will say we cannot take NATO
expansion off the table that is
non-negotiable well hold on a second if
this was nothing to do with NATO
expansion why can't you take it off the
table this war has everything to do with
NATO expansion this is a crusade okay
that goes back many years okay our state
department has been engaged on this
long-term project to basically bring
NATO right up to Russia's borders right
and that has provoked a very strong
response from Russia by the way I'm not
justifying The Invasion it was wrong it
was criminal but the fact of the matter
is that we could have diffused this
crisis Before the War Began if we were
willing to use diplomacy and I I believe
that even today we could try to engage
in diplomacy take NATO expansion off the
table recognize that Crimea is a fatal
to complete and then support some sort
of negotiated settlement over this
donbass region if we were just to agree
to those three things which seemed very
sensible America has no vital interest
and any of those three things that would
supersede or that would necessitate us
to get into a war with Russia if we were
just to do those things I believe
there's a good chance we could end this
war and and in some ways is it almost a
moot point whether they were to get in
NATO or not because if we're in an
endless war that we're funding whether
they're in it or not we're kind of in it
that's the point right well a couple of
things so first of all obviously Ukraine
is more than capable of Defending
themselves if we sell them weapons
without them being in NATO so if this
war has proven anything it's that
Ukraine doesn't need to be in NATO
furthermore however we need to think
about is it really in America's interest
for Ukraine to be in NATO because if if
Ukraine were in NATO they would have an
article 5 guarantee which means the next
time that they get in a war with Russia
and they will because that Feud's been
going on for hundreds of years we will
be instantly obligated to get in a war
with Russia this is why historically we
have not brought them into NATO this is
why there was reluctance we stated Our
intention to do so back in 2008 and we
were solely building towards it but
there was always concern that if we were
actually to bring Ukraine into NATO
would obligate us to get into a war with
Russia and by the way if you like the
feeling that of living with a nuclear
threat remember when I was a kid we we
lived under this threat of nuclear
Annihilation we had movies like the day
after that showed what it was like if we
got a nuclear war I remember that as a
kid it was not a good feeling to grow up
living under the shadow of nuclear
Annihilation we solved that problem we
won the Cold War in 1991 and now it is
back it is back we have been living this
year under the shadow of a nuclear war
so listen if you like that feeling then
by all means bring Ukraine into NATO as
soon as possible because we will be
forever living under the threat of
nuclear Annihilation because again
Article 5 will trigger us to get into a
nuclear war with Russia so it is a
foolish idea it was always a foolish
idea it is not an American interest to
bring Ukraine into NATO and yet these
Crusaders in the state department have
made it their mission and we need to
take that issue off the table as soon as
possible
sax that is a Primo close however I am
going to ask you one other thing but I
do want to just give a shout out to your
Newsweek piece which was called the
neocons and the woke left are joining
hands and leading us to woke War III
we'll also link to that down below now I
just want to ask you one something sort
of personal on all this which is that
you're obviously doing all right you
don't need to be taking the slings and
arrows for this thing uh yet you're
doing it and and it's interesting to me
as I said before that suddenly I'm
finding the people that I'm interested
in politically are tech people and
business people they're not the politics
people uh but it can't be all fun doing
this for you even though I know I know
you care about it and all that stuff but
like you know you're putting your neck
out there you have businesses and all
those things
Dave if I saw more people who are part
of the foreign policy establishment
speaking out and being just a little bit
Brave willing to basically be called a
pro-russian puppet to advocate for
diplomacy and peace they wouldn't be on
people like me to do it but the fact of
the matter is I don't care what these
people say okay I have I've told you
before I got no business interests I'm
not part of this foreign policy
establishment I'm not beholden to their
sort of Insider club and you know what
if we get into war with Russia then you
know that's going to interrupt the uh
the operations of my uh my Venture fund
let's just say that okay we're gonna
have much more important things to worry
about than my next stop investment so
it's my obligation as an American
citizen to speak out I believe that is
why Elon Musk out he is a very informed
person by the way he knows people all
over the world he is very concerned
about this just Rita's tweets he's
taking a lot of flack too Bill Ackman
recently spoke out who by the way we've
been debating each other on Twitter for
a while about this and he recently spoke
out so you're seeing more and more
people speak out out their only interest
here is that they are concerned about
America and they do not see people in
the foreign policy establishment and
politicians speaking out the way they
should be and that includes the
Republican Party who frankly has
completely dropped the ball on this
issue
David I always tell people if we were
just a little bit braver things would be
a lot better so that I love that finish
uh good talking to you my friend great
to see you thanks Dave if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification Bell